hi this is pressure Locker in this video
I'll describe a mathematical way to
split a cake fairly imagine a cake is to
be split between two people
blue and red there are many different
ways that blue and red could split up
the cake imagine blue makes the offer to
cut the cake into two pieces and then
choose one of the pieces first naturally
this is not a fair offer blue is tempted
to cut the cake into two unequal pieces
and then take the larger piece for
himself so this is not a fair way to
split the cake how can we get to a fair
way the procedure for two people is
known as I cut you choose that would
mean that blue cuts the cake but then
red gets to choose which slice first now
with blue cuts the cake into two unequal
slices red is going to pick the larger
slice leaving the smaller slice for blue
so this in turn is going to change the
way that blue cuts the cake you can see
that blue is going to want to cut it to
be 50/50 let's prove this mathematically
imagine that X is the fraction of the
pie that goes from zero to one or it's a
percentage zero to 100% so blue cuts the
cake into two slices X and one minus x
red is going to pick the larger of the
two pieces written as the maximal
function of X and one minus X this will
leave blue with the minimal of the two
values X and one minus X now blue wants
to get the largest piece possible so
blue is going to look at the graph of x
and 1 minus X being minimal and then
choose the largest value of this graph
you can see that if any value of x is
less than 1/2 or more than 1/2 the value
of the graph is going to be less than
0.5 so blue can get the most value by
picking the value of exactly 0.5 so blue
is going to want to solve by cutting the
two slices into exactly 50/50
this leaves blue and red getting 50% of
the cake each
what would happen if we had three people
cutting the cake how can we divide the
cake fairly what we're going to do is
we're going to divide up the first slice
by what's known as the last diminisher
method blue is going to cut a slice of
the cake and it could be any size of
blue wants now red is then going to
inspect the slice and red can reduce the
slice of red wants so let's say red cuts
the slice and then attaches the
remaining part of the cake together so
now this is a slice that red has cut
finally green can look at that slice and
say well I can reduce it a little bit
more to so let's say green reduces a
slice now the last person who cuts the
slice is the one who's going to get that
slice so what is that going to do with
the incentives when we look at how blue
and red are going to cut the cake well a
blue or red actually make a cut to less
than one third then blue a red no one's
going to want to cut the cake after that
so the person who cuts it to less than
one third is going to end up with less
than an even split so no one's going to
want to make the slice too small to
begin with but on the other hand blue or
red are not going to want to leave more
than 1/3 because if they leave more than
1/3 then Brett then green is just going
to cut a very sliver of a slice and then
get more than an even split so blue or
red are actually going to do their best
job to make sure the slice gets to be
about 1/3 and that's why the first slice
is going to be basically 1/3 and it's
going to go to whoever cut it last so
let's suppose that red makes it exactly
1/3 and then red gets the slice so now
we have a situation where blue and green
still need slices of the cake and
there's 2/3 of the cake left so how can
we get two people to split up the
remaining 2/3 of the cake evenly well
we've already solved that problem we
have blue and green play the I cut you
choose procedure for two people so let's
say blue cuts the cake and then green
gets to choose first as we've just shown
this is going to result in a 50/50 split
of the remaining cake so now blue and
green end up
with also slices which are 1/3 each so
now we've cut the cake into three
different slices and three people have
shared the cake evenly to be one third
this last diminisher method can be
generalized if we have even more people
it works inductively person one first
cuts the slice and then the people after
that can inspect the slice and decide
whether to cut off a little bit the same
rule applies that the last person to cut
the slice is the one who's going to end
up with it the procedure is going to
give the incentive that the first slice
is going to be getting to one over N of
the cake we then repeat the procedure
after that one person gets the slice and
then the remaining people are going to
use the same method to cut the next
slice and for the very same reason the
next slice is also going to be 1 over n
and so on we keep repeating this until
there are exactly two people remaining
at which point they do the I cut you
choose method and they are also going to
end up with 1 over n of the cake so this
is the mathematically fair way that you
could split up the cake between any
number of people I hope you like this
video please subscribe to my channel I
make videos on math and game theory you
can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media app brush
teleworker
and if you liked this video please check
out my books there links in the video
description